this idea of a nerd-off number this came
up after he passed away today after you
know before he knew about it yeah yeah
he even kind of promoted he said and a
fundamental problem in mathematics a
kind of a joke to see you connect to
people if they have a joint paper and
this is like constructing a graph where
the points are the people that you put
an edge if they have a joint paper he
cared a lot about collaboration and
joint papers and joint work and so he
had a lot of co-authors he had a theory
and not a real theory that if he had
more living co-authors than dead
co-authors he'd be okay you see somehow
as soon as the number of dead ones
started you know overwhelming the living
was that he knows his time is coming too
every day she had another variation if
you have n papers with him you already
she never should be one over n it's
close to zero so mines 1 over 27 or 28
something like that but there are people
have about 60 papers so but you know it
isn't always just a number under y ou
doesn't have that many papers and still
pretty well known write it so her in
mathematics there are more I think it's
probably true in a lot of fields but I
know about the math people publish under
pseudonyms ok so here's an air dish
number story of a pseudonym so there was
a paper they were working on air dish
and my wife and Chun and some others are
kleitman at MIT and there was a five
author paper as a small result wasn't a
big thing so we thought why not take the
initials of the authors and make a name
turns out gee Peck Gregory Peck perfect
okay gee Peck I was going to G Peck then
right at the end
another mathematician Doug West
contributed made it simpler better okay
well G W Peck I'll get GW Peck why not
okay so we published under GW Peck
that's good turns out that that I had an
interesting concept and people kind of
picked up on the concept on our starter
set it's called post sets and there were
Peck post sets and in particular
kleitman as a professor Dan kleitman at
MIT
I like the name so much he started
publishing a few small papers under the
name GW Peck MIT well the mathematical
reviews sent letters to MIT Jeff
PACA said we've noticed you're published
in this area would you like to review
for us and Peck said sure so Peck
started reviewing papers and he reviewed
one of Lightman's papers which is a
little incestuous he was the game George
Purdy at Cincinnati I'm the G C was
Chung fan chunk a was kleitman he was
air dish it's good to have a vowel well
it turns out that Doug West never had a
paper with air dish but it was only this
and Jerry Griggs was another
mathematician had a paper with Doug West
but he never had a paper with air dish
so his artist number is one plus I the I
is the imaginary and in the complex
plane that's one plus I that's closer
than distance - so it's an air dish
number kind of an imaginary because it's
an imaginary of course in this paper GW
Peck thanks all of us for proving the
theorems writing the paper and so there
there are a number of papers like this
that you'd never know unless you know
you know like a nilly a nilly is the
daughter of no got along and she's
published like I know a dozen paper she
could probably get a pretty good job
someplace that's just that's a little
throwaway result you put it in ain't no
a so yeah GW Peck so they had a a
reunion kleitman retired they had to
talk by GW Peck I'm supposed to come but
I couldn't come I think Doug West gave a
whole history turns that GW Peck was a
real person George Washington Peck was a
politician Wisconsin and he has old
history and you can find so it turns out
it was a real person that's it you never
know there is just a small postscript to
this story a number of years later Doug
West did write a paper with ear - using
their real names taking his Oh - number
two one and for Jerry Griggs that meant
his Erdos number became to sort of
further away from her - in some respects
I guess thank you to everyone who is
supporting numberphile on patreon
especially these people and also if
you'd like to get this new numberphile
poster check out the links on the screen
and in the video description the posters
by artist Pete McPartlin and full of all
sorts of little details and gems from
numberphile